branches happen on a single repository
of course you can push and pull branches
but when you create one you're creating
it on one single repository so the only
one that could possibly fit that mold is
this one we have one branch and here
we've got a second branch so this one is
a branch cloning involves taking an
existing repository and making one just
like it
the original repository could either be
remote like in this case so here we
cloned from github to local or you can
even clone a local repository into
another spot on your computer we haven't
really talked about this so this one was
probably a little tricky this one looks
a lot like a clone too but remember when
you're cloning a repository from github
on to github you do that using github
built-in fork feature forking is only
used within the context of github taking
an existing github repository and making
a copy of it whereas clone works on any
two repositories